vor dem landgericht münster hat am
dienstag ein weiterer prozess gegen
einen angeklagten missbraucht komplex
münster begonnen der in aachen wohnhafte
juni scb im juni 2020 festgenommen
worden
ihm wird schwerer sexueller missbrauch
von kindern vorgeworfen ein
strafverfahren richtet sich gegen einen
27 jahre alten mann aus aachen dem miss
aus taten zum nachteil von insgesamt
drei kindern zu last gelegt werden
der tatzeitraum erstreckt sich von april
2009 10 bis juni 2020 im zeitpunkt
seiner festnahme bei den opfern soll es
sich zum einen um zwei jungen aus
dortmund handeln die seinem
verwandtschaftlichen umfeld zugerechnet
werden
weiteres opfer soll der zehnjährige sohn
des adrian v sein der als schlüsselfigur
zahner dass prozesse gilt tatort soll
neben der wohnung in münster unter
gartenlaube in münster zwei
ferienwohnungen gewesen sein denn ich in
winterberg und ihr nach mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren